hey everyone it's steve weintraub here
with collider and i am thrilled to
introduce mike judge um
i i am a huge fan of your work i am so
thankful you decided to come in today to
talk thank you um i have so many
questions and i want to start with first
when did you realize you were not
nostradamus
with idiocracy when did it hit you that
you can predict the future
i would say well
it started fairly
early on like when okay like here's one
example
in the movie uh
our wardrobe designer
uh
had said you know it was sort of like
you know you have to make you're doing a
movie in the future you have to invent
everything
and to make it easier she was saying
well here's this there's a startup
that's making these really stupid
looking shoes made out of plastic
they're called crocs so we shot in 2004
and um i'm looking at these things and i
go i said yeah those would be great but
if it's a real startup and what if they
come out what if they become popular and
then by the time the movie comes out
people are wearing them then we're not a
future movie or set in the present
she said oh no one's ever gonna buy
these things don't worry about that
and the movie came out two years after
we shot it and everyone's wearing crocs
so that was my first indication that
uh things were going that direction and
then just over the years yeah people it
was sort of a slow burn people just kept
texting me like oh there's this coffee
place in seattle where the girls wear
lingerie and it's like a hooters coffee
place or something and then
yeah one thing after another and then
there's trump and then it's just like
and now everyone's just like yeah
i'm afraid to watch the movie now i have
president camacho coming in tomorrow
nice so we'll talk about something else
but you can bet your ass i'm going to
bring up being president yeah terry
terry really kind of made that character
his own yeah you should ask him about
that he because he's got some great
stories about kind of his
inspiration because originally i was
thinking something a little bit
different and um i think i thought about
benicio del toro or something and
terry came in and just kind of stole the
part like he had this sort of preacher
thing and it was god it was just it was
so good
i have to ask you you've directed a few
films um uh you know live action um have
you have you come close to directing
something else live action um because
you haven't done anything i believe
since extract
yeah um
yeah um there's there's been a couple
things there's one that's getting pretty
close actually um i don't think i'm
allowed to say yet but but uh
i might be directing something uh
fairly soon uh early next year maybe
paramount plus netflix students doesn't
have a this is a it's not found a home
there's a uh
company
uh picture start but it but
it's we haven't uh
i don't know how the business of it all
works but there would be it would then
go to a bigger sure did you write the
script yourself uh co-wrote the story
and working on it uh well i don't know
if i'm allowed to say any of this but
right
by the way i love it when people come in
and start saying that i don't want to
get you in trouble but i will just say
that i'll leave it alone and i'm just
going to say i i hope you're doing some
a live action thing soon but let's move
into the reason i actually get to talk
to you today which is the wind the wind
being so strong
this is god saying um yeah so with the
older episodes of beavis and butthead i
don't know how many are available with
the music videos and everything like
that
do you wish at all you could go back in
time and adjust a contract
yeah
yeah i mean that's that's the problem i
i mean a lot of the stuff i'm most proud
of is
the commentary in the music videos i
mean there's some at the beginning where
beavers and buddha are hardly talking at
all because i i thought at the start of
it i thought oh people watch mtv because
they want to watch the videos they're
not going to want these guys talking
over the whole thing which i was wrong
about uh
but
but um
yeah i mean the thing is that they those
contracts were just for mtv but
apparently
i'm hearing different things apparently
they're trying to get it and they might
be able to get it so they'll just play
the way they played originally with all
the videos in them which is kind of like
what the rhythm of it was and
what i i liked about it so i'm i'm
hoping to get that i
um
yeah just for people out there it's not
my
sure i wish they were that way i can't
get it another thing happened too on the
dvds where
they had to cut some lines for like
standards and practices are different on
dvds and they would put directors cut
whenever that happened
and i got all this
not just a few very angry people saying
like why mike judge shouldn't be allowed
to touch this [ __ ] like you know and it
wasn't me it was just because of same
thing with the videos like i we but but
it looks like i'm hopeful that they
might be able to actually release them
as they were there there's
something in the contracts because this
is mtv
uh it's it's an mtv company i think they
might be able to do it uh so the new
beavis and butthead series is coming out
uh next month are you done with
everything are you still working on it
no still working on it we're
we're uh
we're cutting it fairly close
everybody august 4th they're there it
starts coming out but um
i think we got some really good stuff
there's uh
um some of the episodes are gonna be
they're gonna be middle-aged we do do
that kind of quantum split in the movie
um
so those those have been fun to do too
what can you tease people about the
storyline of what do you want to tease
people about the episodes and maybe how
it compares to the original show
i mean i think we've stayed pretty true
to who the characters are but there's a
lot of fun stuff there's uh
they they watch youtube videos and tick
tock videos now which has been a lot of
fun to do
um
they uh let's see we have like i say we
have episodes where they're
middle aged
butthead is just like this
big old useless guy they're on all kinds
of government assistance they're like
their burden on society but uh it's been
very fun to do and and the old beavis
and blooded watch music videos too um
but yeah we've got uh
we've got an episode got one episode the
butthead's not even in where beavis uh
sees a there's a fire and a dumpster
fire and it starts talking to him giving
him commands
uh let's see what else
i keep thinking of the the first we have
one where they're
um
at a mall they they have uh
these uh they think they're virtual
reality glasses they're just sunglasses
and they think the mall is one game and
they
try to kill themselves to get back to
the beginning
um listen i i'm just about out of time
with you but my friend mike is a super
fan of yours and a super fan of beavis
and butthead and he gave me a question
and i want to ask it because he is such
a fan so and i'm gonna read it uh beavis
is a lovable idiot but butthead shows
the occasional sign of minimal
intelligence which makes his stupidity
even funnier was that your intention
when creating the characters
i think
that
originally i was i was thinking beavis
is just this
his brain's fried from sniffing glue and
he just kind of cackles
but uh then as the show went on you know
when you have to do
200 episodes
it
yeah i wanted i started to think maybe
beavis does have this
occasional flashes these occasional
flashes of genius but buddha just stamps
it right out of him and
so there's no hope for him but uh but
yeah that was that was a conscious thing
that came along after it became a show
um i could ask you a million questions
but i think you already have to go i'm
just gonna say a sincere thank you for
coming in oh thank you
you